[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Christian Sievers
guten Abend ihnen es ist gerade mal
einen Tag her seit Vladimir Putin vier
ukrainische Gebiete gegen das
Völkerrecht seinem eigenen Land
einverleibt hatte da muss die russische
Armee eine strategisch wichtige Stadt
aufgeben die sie ja eigentlich seit
gestern als Teil Russlands betrachten
wollte blau-gelbe Flaggen über limane
eine deutliche Niederlage der Russen die
gegen Offensive ukrainischer Truppen im
Osten macht weiter Boden gut Sarah
Hassan seitdem mit mehr
ukrainische Soldaten zeigen dass sie die
russische Armee vertrieben haben
auf dem Ortsschild limans hissen sie die
ukrainische Fahne der Soldat sagt limane
wird wieder Ukrainisch
es tauchen weitere Videos über den
ukrainischen Vormarsch auf Liman in den
sozialen Netzen auf alle nicht
unabhängig überprüfbar doch
Glaubwürdigkeit erhalten die Aufnahmen
ausgerechnet durch das russische Militär
wegen des Risikos eingekesselt zu werden
haben wir die Truppen aus Liman
abgezogen
ein Tag nach der Annektion muss die
russische Armee sich zurückziehen und
den ukrainischen Streitkräften steht der
Weg offen nach Johannes noch gibt es
keine Angaben wie viele russische
Soldaten gefallen oder gefangen genommen
wurden oder sich zurückziehen konnten es
sind alte Panzer aus der Sowjet Zeit mit
denen die Ukrainer im Nordosten
vorrücken und die sie hier in Odessa der
deutschen Verteidigungsministerin
Lambrecht vorführen die Worte Leopard
und Marder schweben förmlich über ihrem
Besuch selbst wenn sie nicht
ausgesprochen werden in wenigen Tagen
das hochmoderne Luftverteidigungssystem
ihres Tee geliefert das ist ganz wichtig
dass hier abgewehrt werden kann und
darüber hinaus geht es auch um
thronenabwehr ganz wichtig und da haben
wir schon geliefert aber wir werden
jetzt da auch noch mal zusätzlich
liefern wie sehr sich die Ukraine am
moderne Kampfpanzer wünschen wird der
Ministerin heute wohl nicht entgangen
sein ihre Besprechung mit dem
ukrainischen Verteidigungsminister
resnikow musste im Luftschutzkeller
fortgeführt werden es gab Luftalarm
der militärische Erfolg im Nordosten
bringt auch Gräueltaten des Krieges ans
Licht diese Menschen wollten in
Privatautos aus dem russisch besetzten
Gebiet flüchten sie wurden beschossen
dieser Konvoi war zwischen den Orten
Kiri Lifka und pisana unterwegs wir
haben 24 Leichname gezählt davon 13
Kinder und eine schwangere Frau
Augenzeugen sagen dass russische
Soldaten das Feuer eröffnet hätten
Russland bestreitet dies
[Applaus]
in Deutschland kennen wir das Szenario
bereits und müssen mit den Folgen klar
kommen jetzt trifft es Italien und die
besonders von russischem Gas abhängige
Republik Moldau eines der ärmsten Länder
Europas der russische Konzern Gast Brom
hat die Gaslieferungen drastisch
zurückgefahren nach Italien aktuell auf
0 nach Moldau auf nur noch 70 Prozent
und droht auch dort mit einem kompletten
Stopp unsere Nachbarin in Polen waren ja
schon länger sehr skeptisch wenn es um
Gas aus Russland ging sie feiern jetzt
die Eröffnung einer neuen Pipeline die
Gas aus Norwegen bringen soll bislang
fehlen aber ausreichend Lieferverträge
und auch norwegisches Gas ist sehr teuer
das ganze ein Infrastrukturprojekt mit
einigen Fragezeichen Natalie Steger
so berichtet das unabhängige polnische
Privatfernsehen diese Woche über die
Eröffnung der Baltic Pipe und gleicht
der optische Seitenhieb auf Deutschland
mit Russland einst seit an seit bei
nordstream Polen hat Moskau immer
misstraut seit heute fließt Gas aus
Norwegen direkt nach Polen Polen war das
erste Land die im Russland im April den
Gashahn zugedreht hatte nun liefert die
Baltic pipe
dank dieser Rohre können wir nicht nur
unabhängig von Russland den gasmix
gestalten sondern perspektivisch auch
weiteren Ländern helfen wie Tschechien
oder der Slowakei die ebenfalls ihren
Mix von Russland unabhängig machen
wollen
allerdings läuft der Staat holprig
Lieferverträge wurden erst in letzter
Minute abgeschlossen weil Polen versucht
hatte den norwegischen Lieferanten im
Preis zu drücken jetzt zahlt es den
Marktpreis die Baltic pipe ist eine
Abzweigung der Europe 2 das Gas fließt
aus Norwegen via Dänemark auf 900
Kilometern könnte in Zukunft etwa die
Hälfte des polnischen Jahresbedarfs
stecken aber noch fließt eben nur ein
Teil dabei wollte Polen schon weit vor
dem ukrainekrieg Weg vom Menschen Gas
vor 15 Jahren beschlossen diese Woche
eröffnet seit heute in Betrieb
[Applaus]
wir treten in eine neue Ära ein eine
Ära der energie-souveränität Energie
Freiheit und verstärkte Energie
Sicherheit
eine Fertigstellung in einer Zeit in der
Russland brutal Krieg führt gegen die
Ukraine und der russischen Manipulation
von Gaslieferungen um unseren
Energiemarkt unsere Wirtschaften zu
destabilisieren
obwohl in Polen noch die
Kohleverstromung eine große Rolle spielt
für die Industrie wird Gas zunehmend
gebraucht der kohleanteil soll sinken
außerdem heizen in den großen Städten
die Mehrheit der polnischen Haushalte
mit Gas
Polen investiert in die Gasversorgung
neue pipeline-ausbau des lng-terminals
in Swinemünde mit internationalen
Lieferungen manch andere Projekte
verzögern sich allerdings nach den
Attacken auf Nord Stream 1 und 2 stellt
sich nun auch bei der Baltic pipe die
Frage nach der Sicherheit
solch eine Infrastruktur braucht ein
komplexes Abwehrsystem das es einigen
Segmenten besteht vor allem ist
Spionageabwehr wichtig dazu auch die
Überwachung durch Satelliten und Drohnen
perspektivisch Energiesicherheit
irgendwann ist das eine hohe
gasmarktpreise Beuteln Polen trotzdem
trotz der neuen Pipeline der Winter wird
für die Polen teuer
ein polnischer Traum wie der
Staatspräsident sagt geht in Erfüllung
auch wenn die Pipeline aktuell nur mäßig
ausgelastet ist gleichzeitig steigen die
sorgen dass diese Energie Infrastruktur
eben sehr verletzlich ist wie wir diese
Woche gerade erlebt haben Ultra ist
unser eu-korrespondent guten Abend Ulf
nächste Woche wollen die Staats- und
Regierungschefs über die
pipeline-sicherheit reden haben die denn
eine Idee wie diese gigantische
Infrastruktur überhaupt zu schützen wäre
das Thema ist ja eigentlich nicht ganz
neu schon länger hat sich die
Europäische Kommission und auch die NATO
mit dem Thema beschäftigt wie man die
Infrastruktur vor allem unter Wasser
sichern kann weil man muss doch ganz
klar sagen und das hat auch der Anschlag
gezeigt dort liegen Stromkabel dort
liegen Internetkabel und wenn die
zerstört werden dann gehen ganze
Regionen das Licht aus und das wäre
dramatisch deswegen hat man sich damit
beschäftigt aber man hat sich nicht so
mit dem Nachdruck beschäftigt und es war
mehr ein Thema für Experten als für
Regierungschefs jetzt sind die
Regierungschefs dran die werden sich
nächste Woche Donnerstag und Freitag in
Prag treffen und ich könnte mir schon
vorstellen dass man ein Paket vielleicht
präsentieren wird man wird mit
Sicherheit mehr Geld in die Rüstung
stecken man wird also unter Wasser
aufrüsten neue Technik machen und mehr
Kontrollfahrten machen ob das am Ende
wirklich dazu führt dass man wirklich
mehr Sicherheit hat für die
Infrastruktur das sind doch sehr sehr
viele Experten sehr sehr kritisch die
Ostsee dort wo der Anschlag
stattgefunden hat war ja eine
unglaublich gut überwachte Region und
trotzdem konnte das passieren wenn man
jetzt an den Atlantik denkt der ganz
wichtige Infrastruktur hat da ist das
Wasser viel tiefer und größer also das
wird sehr sehr schwierig sein vielleicht
ist das ein Zeichen dieser neuen
zeitenwände von der alle reden dass wir
eben lernen müssen mit diesen
Bedrohungen zu leben ultra ZDF Brüssel
vielen Dank Wolf den Kontakt zur EU
abbrechen zur arroganten Brüsseler
EU-Bürokratie wie er sagt das will der
serbische Vertreter im Staatspräsidium
von Bosnien und Herzegowina und er sagt
auch er wolle Zitat mit Führern
zusammenarbeiten die das internationale
Recht respektieren wie etwa Vladimir
Putin
da kommt etwas auf Europa zu mitten in
Europa in Bosnien und Herzegowina sind
an diesem Wochenende ebenso
entscheidende wie komplizierte Wahlen
Britta Hilpert berichtet so schön ist
Bosnien und Herzegowina und so vernarbt
durch seine Vergangenheit sogar hier
oben trifft man auf alte Schützengräben
in diesen Schützengräben sitzen manche
Politiker im Wahlkampf bis heute
ethnische Spannungen stiegen zuletzt
seit Anfang September ist deshalb die
Bundeswehr zurück das Liaison und
observation Team soll Kontakte und
Gespräche suchen Spannungen
wo haben sie es gelernt nein unsere
Anwesenheit hat schon einen
psychologischen Effekt wir sind wirklich
da und sind wirklich mit den Menschen im
Gespräch allein das stabilisiert
ungemein im Wahlkampf zündet besonders
Serbenführer Dodik Muslime und Christen
könnten nicht zusammen leben sagt er und
fordert die Abspaltung der re:publikas
ripska Putin unterstützt ihn darin
US-Geheimdienste vermuten Geldflüsse in
der republikas ripska sind
nationalistische Gruppen aktiv die
offenbar von Russland gesponsert werden
wie ihr Bus zeigt sie zeigen sich bei
sogenannten humanitären Aktionen treten
trotz Verbot paramilitärisch auf und
manche von ihnen sind bekannte
Straftäter so extremismusforscher Armin
charlitsch
seit zwei Jahren befördern diese Gruppen
die Interessen Russlands in der Region
es verbindet die Gruppen eine gemeinsame
Ideologie so der Professor und die
Freundschaft der Führer dieser
Organisation
Priester
Organisator sie verherrlichen
Kriegsverbrecher und machen den nicht
Serben im Land Angst Europa habe da viel
zu lang tatenlos zugeschaut meint Armin
charlic
diese Gruppen konnten nur deshalb immer
aktiver werden weil NATO und EU
eingeschlafen sind
vor 26 Jahren beendete die
internationale Gemeinschaft den Krieg
doch dann wurde das Land zunehmend
allein gelassen mit den Problemen diese
Wahl zeigt das war ein Fehler
wir ertrinken in Korruption und Unrecht
jetzt wollen die Politiker uns in einen
neuen Krieg reinziehen das hatte ich
schon einmal in Sarajevo Politik doch
Sarah hier überzeugt auch davon das
Zusammenleben möglich ist dafür braucht
es die EU-Perspektive meint der Ruhe
un-beauftragte
da wäre es gut wenn wir so wie andere
Länder Beitrittsverhandlungen bekommen
auch für Bosnien-Herzegowina auch nach
den Wahlen bleibt der Friede prekär weiß
das observation Team die EU-Perspektive
würde vielen hier mehr Sicherheit geben
und Russlands Einfluss etwas
entgegensetzen
so und weitere wichtige Nachrichten von
diesem Samstag bündelst du jetzt für uns
eins zunächst zu den Folgen von Hurrikan
ihren während der sich heute weiter zum
Sturm abgeschwächt hat mit immer mehr
sichtbar welche Zerstörungskraft der
hatte in Florida steigt die Zahl der
gemeldeten Todesopfer inzwischen sind es
mehr als 40 in den Betroffene Gebieten
dort geht die Suche nach Vermissten
weiter der Hurrikan war am Mittwoch mit
Windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu 240
km/h in Florida auf Land getroffen er
zog dann weiter Richtung Nordosten und
erreichte gestern abgeschwächt die Küste
von South Carolina
während die Proteste in Iran weitergehen
haben heute weltweit Menschen ihre
Solidarität gezeigt auch in Deutschland
gingen insgesamt mehr als 10.000
Menschen auf die Straßen wie hier in
Berlin sie forderten ein Ende des
Regimes und mehr Freiheit für Frauen
Auslöser ist der Tod einer jungen Frau
die von der Sittenpolizei verhaftet
worden war und kurz darauf starb
vom heutigen 1 Oktober an gelten neue
bundesweite corona-regeln dazu zählt
eine
ffp2-maskenpflicht etwa ein Arztpraxen
im Krankenhäusern und
Pflegeeinrichtungen sowie im Fernverkehr
bei Bus und Bahn im Regionalverkehr
entscheiden die Bundesländer die auch
weitere Schutzmaßnahmen in anderen
Bereichen anordnen können
und übermorgen am dritten oktober jährt
sich die deutsche Einheit zum 32 Mal
gefeiert wird in diesem Jahr vor allem
in Erfurt das Gastgeber des zentralen
einheitsfestes ist los ging es aber
heute schon mit einem Bürgerfest auf dem
Domplatz die thüringische
Landeshauptstadt erwartet bis Montag
einen großen besucherantrag
und jetzt die Lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 1 3 19 37 43 49 Superzahl 0 und
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im zdf-text auf Seite
es gibt aktuelle Unwetterwarnungen des
Deutschen Wetterdienstes gewarnt wird
vor ergiebigem Dauerregen in Regionen im
Süden von Bayern und jetzt die
Aussichten morgen regnet es südlich des
Mainz länger und teils ergiebig im
Norden ist es wechselhaft mit Schauern
und einzelnen Gewittern an den Küsten
gibt es stürmische Böden die Temperatur
erreicht 14 bis 20 Grad am Montag regnet
es bei 13 bis 19 °c nur im Nordosten und
im Süden etwas ab Dienstag scheint auf
die Sonne und wenn sich der Nebel dann
gelichtet hat und dann kann es sogar
warm werden am Mittwoch 17 bis 24 Grad
das kann 24 Grad gesagt das sind
Aussichten von uns allen hier im heute
journal Team danke für heute gerne bis
morgen und auf Wiedersehen tschüss
[Musik]